on Tuesday renowned legal journal
Cosmopolitan magazine ran a piece titled
nine ways to make your man gasped in bed
no actually they could have run that
piece but we know they actually ran a
piece titled nine reasons constitutional
originalism is bull bleep written by NYU
graduate Jill philipovich the article
evidence is all of the brilliant
jurisprudential analyses we've come to
expect from the journal that informs you
which sex positions best tickle your
significant other properly here are
Philip Kovach's nine critiques one no
one is really an original is Tom Povich
argues the judges don't actually pay
attention to the original wording and
meaning of the Constitution instead
substituting their own policy
preferences as evidence she chooses DC
vs Heller a decision that rien shrine
the individual right to keep and bear
arms why isn't that original list
because Philip ovitch says the founders
meant to restrict arms ownership which
remembers and didn't know what handguns
Wars is a direct quote nor of course did
handguns exist in the 18th century both
of these contentions are false militia
members were members of the community
there are many state laws that required
all able-bodied men of age to own a gun
so as to be available for militia duty
the militia Clause is a justifying
clause not an operative one and handguns
were news as early as the 14th century
two societies evolved and that's a good
thing Philip ovitch argues that
scientific knowledge is impact how we
interpret the Constitution for example
brain science should help determine what
the founders meant by cruel and unusual
punishment but we have legislators for
that a constitution bands cruel and
unusual punishment the legislators can
outlaw certain tools she mixes up the
role of the courts to apply the meaning
of the law and that of the legislature
to make policy she even says she hopes
the court should rule capital punishment
unconstitutional on the spaces even
though the Constitution clearly
contemplates capital punishment multiple
puns third words evolves reflects
changing norms philipovich says that
words like equal meant something
different in the 1790s than they mean
now particularly with regard to women
and minorities she is right this is why
America implemented constitutional
amendment in order to enshrine those new
meanings as for the fourteenth
amendments for black folks and the
nineteenth amendment for female folks it
is not the job of course to rewrite
meaning for technology evolves and the
law has to keep up Philip ovitch argues
is difficult to apply constitutional
principles to modern technology so for
example the provisions of the
constitution guaranteeing Liberty from
unreason
search and seizure how would they apply
to cars or wiretaps these are indeed
controversial propositions in original
circles but that doesn't mean we oughta
merely ignore what the framers intended
in principle in order to return on
policy preferences 5th originalism is a
cover for legal discrimination again
this ignores the fact that we have
legislators in this country you can't
rewrite counting documents to implement
your own version of utopia atilla Povich
says correctly that quote a lot of our
laws originally allowed a lot of
terrible acts this is true it is also
the reason we have you guessed it
legislators and amendment she says the
Plessy versus Ferguson which said
segregation was okay and was reversed by
Brown versus Board of Education is a
good example of course evolving she
ignored the fact that Leslie was
arguably wrongly decided on his merits
at the time that's the case Justice
Scalia made during his career stating
the quote in my view the Fourteenth
Amendments requirements of equal
protection of the laws combined with the
Thirteenth Amendment abolition of the
institution of black slavery leaves no
room for doubt that was treating people
differently because of their rates are
invalid even if Scalia was wrong on
original asst grounds that doesn't mean
the legislature could not or should not
have taken the proper measures again
courts are not legislators and just
because history was full of bad stuff
doesn't mean the Constitution doesn't
provide mechanisms to fix that bad stuff
outside of Joe philipovich convincing
Ruth Bader Ginsburg to run roughshod
over the Republic 6 contention not even
the founders were original 'used this is
just horse crap philipovich says quote
the framers of the Constitution didn't
offer any instructions for how to
interpret the document actually it's
dubious whether the founders even agreed
with judicial review but if they did
there's no doubt they would have hated
the courts usurpation of legislative
power see for example Alexander Hamilton
in Federalist 78 quote the courts must
declare the sense of the law and if they
should be disposed to exercise will
instead of judgment the consequence
would be equally the substitution of
their pleasure to that of the
legislative body the observation if it
proved anything would prove there ought
not be any judges distinct from that
body all laws are applied as written no
judge would dare interpret the sherman
antitrust act the way leftists
encouraged judges to interpret the
Constitution 7 contention from Cosmo
magazine the founders weren't fortune
tellers and couldn't predict every
possible legal issue here Philip ovitch
states that quote many of the realities
of modern life didn't exist in the 18th
century that's true you know who else do
that
others because they relied on
legislators to create law Phillip Povich
makes the idiotic assessment that if
you're an originalist if the founders
quote didn't specifically by the
government from doing something the
government is free to do it that's
insane that looks only to the bill of
rights not to the structural
constitution which delegates powers the
founders explicitly rejected philipovich
is logic and said so in the Ninth
Amendment which reserved rights to the
states and to the people as for
philipovich his example of governments
doing bad things at the state level
again true the founders recognized that
and relied on people not to be complete
morons but they didn't trust the people
completely which is why they created
some federal rights eight no one really
wants to live in an originalist
countries I do if she means that
legislators legislators should legislate
and get this judges should adjudicate
she quotes UC Irvine law professor Erwin
Chemerinsky for the proposition that if
the court didn't impose its will quote
this would mean the end of
constitutional protection for liberties
such as the right to marry the right to
procreate the right to custody of one's
children and the list goes on yet
magically for decades the court did not
read its preferences into the
Constitution and yet the country didn't
descend into chaos and anarchy that's
because we elect people here yes
legislators exist ninth and final point
a constitution that doesn't reflect
changing norms and realities is a
constitution that would eventually
proved itself ineffectual and irrelevant
Phillip Povich says the judicial system
cannot be neutered what's it failed to
check the other branches except that she
wants the other branch has to be
incapable of checking the mystical
wisdom of the judicial Oleg arcing a
constitution that changes at the whim of
nine unelected judges means a country
ruled by a quick not by the people or
their elected representatives even
philipovich have to admit quote of
course the Constitution should be
interpreted as it's written but she then
says that what you mean is that judges
should interpret it as they wish it had
been written the Constitution in other
words should have more positions in been
Cosmo and they will all be less
satisfying I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
okay that lengthy introduction was meant
to illuminate you to the issues
surrounding what the left think of what
judges are supposed to do and what the
right thing is what judges are supposed
to do and that means as you can hear all
the logic all of the decency is on the
side of the right on this one when it
comes to originalism the decency in the
judiciary is all on the side of the
right and we're about to go through what
should be the best time of trump
presidency so far the gorge hearing that
happened yesterday the day before
they're happening today as well judge
course which is doing a terrific job in
front of the Judiciary Committee I'll
talk about some problems with the system
of judicial nominations and why they're
a problem why they why that system is
crappy we'll talk about that in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our advertisers over at tracker com
tracker may have saved my marriage my
wife loses her phone every single day
she also loses turkeys well actually I
have to admit I lose my keys and wallet
a lot to track her is things like the
size of a coin and you attach it to the
object that you're afraid you're going
to lose and then you can call it and
then it tells you exactly where it is it
rings beeps is finding over a million
misplaced items every day order yours
right now and you will never lose
anything again I promise you I use it
all the time myself as the tracker com
promo code Ben and you get a free tract
of Bravo with any order great product
very excited to be associated with them
and thank you tracker for helping my
marriage be better because it means that
I'm less annoyed with my wife my wife is
what's annoyed with me and once you more
than you I tracker com flash bed and you
get that discount so it's really
terrific again a terrific piece of
technology and thanks to Austin and the
crew for making that beautiful animation
my wife fell looking to kill me really
really appreciate that okay so the news
yesterday and this week outside of the
gorse is sharon has not been good for
president Trump will talk about Trump
care in a little while we'll also talk
about some of the issues surrounding
Russian connections the big story about
Paul man afford who is the former Trump
campaign manager apparently he was
working very closely with Vladimir
Putin's allies for a number of years I
will get to that in a little while but
first I want to talk about what should
be the high water mark for Trump's
presidency the reason I want to talk
about this is because i want to point
something out a lot of people have been
saying that nationalist populism this
kind of
style trumpism that that is where the
popularity of republicanism and
conservatism are going to lie that if we
change over to this nationalist populism
that's where conservatism is really
going to be great that's where that's
where conservatism is really going to be
able to do yeoman's work the gore
securing shows the opposite the gorgish
hearing shows that traditional
conservatism and I mean small-government
traditional conservatism with checks and
balance and separation of powers is
still a more powerful idea than the idea
of some great god-king on a hill
deciding who gets to have a job and who
doesn't get to have a job corsa she's
hearing are the best thing that could
have happened to trump there they were
great judge course that she did a
terrific job you can see it started off
with Ted Cruz the senator from Texas
asking Neil Gorsuch about originalism
and seeding democrats of caricatured the
thing it serves well to rebut the
caricature that some on the left try to
paint of original list and so under the
caricature that some of the Democrats
have suggested you would assume the
original lyst in the case would all line
up on the side of saying well gosh the
Fourth Amendment doesn't cover that and
and yet the Kyllo case the majority
opinion 54 was written by Justice Scalia
perhaps the leading original 'used on
the court okay and he's right about that
Gorsuch proved in this hearing that
originalism is a is a hardy philosophy
that makes perfect sense again the
judiciary has a different role than the
legislature okay legislators make law
the judiciary applies the law according
to the wording of the law when the
judiciary starts doing its own thing as
Alexander Hamilton said it loses its
reason for existence and gorse is very
clear on this which is why you know it's
interesting i'm not sure that Trump is
going to be all entirely happy with
every decision Gorsuch makes so all
credit to trump for nominating somebody
who may rule against him in certain
cases here is judge courses talking
about what it means to be a judge says
your personal views should not decide
the law my personal views I'd also tell
you mr. chairman along over here I leave
those that mr. Koch l yesterday said
that what he wants is a fair judge
that's what I wanted as a lawyer I just
wanted to judge come in and decide on
the facts and the law of my clients case
and leave what he had for breakfast to
the breakfast table
and part of being a good judge is coming
in and taking precedent as it stands and
your personal views about the precedent
have absolutely nothing to do with a
good job of a judge okay so the last
thing that he says there is actually
somewhat troubling for conservatives and
I would like to see conservatives drill
down on this so there's something in
judicial philosophy called star decisis
star decisis means the case has already
been decided it just means precedent
there's always been a lot of controversy
over how much respect to give to
precedents and the case has already been
decided is it something that you should
follow or is it not so there are lots of
cases in American history where the
judiciary has decided that a case was
wrongly decided 50 years before and they
overturn it roe v wade would be a good
one to do right now and we still don't
know what gorsuch would do about roe v
wade you know the in case it in history
where we overturn the judgment include
things like 20 versus ferguson and brown
versus board as i mentioned Plessy
versus Ferguson said segregation was
okay Brown vs. Board says it's not
another obvious case is obergefell about
gay marriage which overturns a bunch of
a whole string of cases at the Supreme
Court level Lawrence v Texas which said
that there was no state capacity to
criminalize homosexual activity that
overturned a much earlier case called
powers versus Hardwick in 1989 ceau star
decisis is really a way for judges to
pick and choose and this is why I hope
that the conservatives in this committee
drilled down on Gorsuch and say okay how
do you decide when precedent rules and
when president is not the most
consistent person philosophically on
this at the court was not Scalia
actually it's Clarence Thomas who says
sorry decisis is stupid basically if the
case was wrongly decided I'm not going
to pretend that it's a better decision
just because it was decided 10 years ago
or 20 years ago the reason that this
matters is because here is for example
Gorsuch talking about roe v wade as
president is clip 8 one of the facts and
one of the features of law that you have
to decide it on the basis of precedent
as you point out and for a judge
precedent is a very important thing we
don't go reinvent the wheel every day
and and that's the equivalent point of
the law of precedent we have an entire
law about precedent the law of judicial
precedent
precedent about precedent if you will so
just all factors that a good judge will
take into consideration when examining
any precedent you start with a heavy
heavy presumption in favor of press
Alexander Hamilton said that's one
important feature big was Hamilton said
one important feature of judges if we're
going to give them life tenure and allow
them that extraordinary privilege they
should be bound down by strict rules and
precedence okay so they can hear you
here here's the problem with some of
this and the reason I don't believe in
precedents again it allows you to pick
which presidents you choose to follow on
which ones you don't what would be
really great in these hearings honestly
and the reason the only reason to have
these hearings Democrats destroyed the
notion of a judicial hearing it used to
be that you could just say to a judge
okay roe v wade add case or good case
every law student every person basically
has an opinion on whether roe v wade is
a bad case earth okay certainly anyone
who's ever read the decision with any
sort of legal head understands it's a
bad decision legally even if you like
the outcome you know it shouldn't be out
of balance to say Rovio a bad decision
or a good decision all right these
should be these are questions we should
want to have answered before we actually
get to put somebody on the Supreme Court
and Democrats don't have any qualms
about asking these questions they say
openly that they have litmus test with
regards to their own people that they
issued these litmus test if people would
would upholds roe v wade than their
appropriate for the court it's not than
they wouldn't but because democrats have
vowed to basically shut down any justice
who has a clear-cut opinion about
important cases well you end up with
these very milquetoast hearings in any
case course it shows a good job with the
milk toast hearings you wouldn't expect
him to come out and say roe v wade is a
crappy case because if he did then
presumably a bunch of democrats would
attempt to fill of us for him and some
republicans would break off and join
because they're weaklings matt said
Gorsuch does a very good job of
navigating smoothly what these hearings
are which is basically an opportunity
for him to explain his philosophy in
most general possible terms and
smackdown allegations against him so
here's an exchange that was pretty great
where dick durbin from illinois who's
just an idiot claims the gore ascension
anti-woman because he once taught an
ethics class in which he talked about
the law regarding sexual harassment and
here's courses you're smacking durban
around like a pinata senator those are
not my words and i would net
red said them I didn't say that I asked
you if you agreed with the statement I'm
telling you I don't I'll worry and
here's the thing about Gorsuch that I do
like is it he seems like somebody who is
not going to be beholden to political
interest so he was asked specifically
about president Trump's attacks on the
judiciary and here is his answer this is
a dive I know these people and I know
how decent they are and when anyone
criticizes the honesty or integrity the
motives of a federal judge well I find
that disheartening I find that
demoralise because I know the truth
anyone including the prep the United
States anyone is anyone okay and and
that is this speaks you know well of
Trump that he nominates a guy who's
willing to gotten say stuff like this
gorsuch really smacked around a bunch of
Democrats yesterday Al Franken was was
was criticizing the confirmation process
and Gorsuch smacked around Franken as
well Center there's a lot about this
process I'm uncomfortable with a lot but
I'm not God no one asked me to fix it
I'm here as a witness trying to
faithfully answer your questions as best
i can consistent with the constraints i
have is a sitting judge okay and and
again that's I think good stuff the fact
that Al Franken these Stuart Stuart
Smalley is out there like quizzing him
is just insane okay the fact that Stuart
Smalley is on the Judiciary Committee
quizzing him about cases he knows
nothing about him he knows nothing about
Chevron deference he knows nothing about
any of these issues it's just completely
crazy but you know that's the way the
system works the biggest problem is I
say with these judicial hearings you
never get any good answers you never get
the answers that you actually want and
that you actually care about so for
example Gorsuch is asked again about roe
v wade by lindsey graham this time he's
asked if Trump asked him to overturn Roe
v waiting here a score such as answer in
that interview did he ever ask you to
overrule roe v wade no senator what
would he have done if he's asked senator
i would have walked out the door
not what judges do I don't do it at that
end of Pennsylvania Avenue and they
shouldn't do it at this end either
detecting today's objecting to the idea
that Trump would ask him to overturn the
ruling okay the fact is that Trump I
hope asked him how would you rule on roe
v wade not you have from ruled to
overturn it but how would you rule i
would ask that if I were president I
would ask any judicial appointee well
how they would rule on the controversial
cases because this is stupid the only
reason you appoint two judges if you
know it made a good long history of
ruling in a certain way now the reason I
like Gore such as a nominee is because
he does have a pretty good judicial
history of ruling on some controversial
issues and he has generally ruled the
correct way but what we've ended up with
is the judicial confirmation process
that actually makes the system more
vague not less vague and that's a real
problem for example Gorsuch is just
asked how he would rule on the Muslim
ban same sort of thing here's what he
says now does the First Amendment allow
the use of a religious litmus test for
entry into the United States Senator
that's an issue that's currently being
litigated actively as you know well and
I'm not asking about the litigation in
the Ninth Circuit or anything else I'm
asking about the fact is a blanket
religious test is that consistent with
the First Amendment Center we have a pre
exercise clause that protects the free
exercise of religious liberties by all
persons in this country this feels
clearer to use and then somebody let me
know in just a minute ago gore session
in the hearings with death whether he
accepted the roe v wade was blogland he
said yes I accept that it's the law of
the land that doesn't mean he wouldn't
overturn it right he could still
overturn it and accept that it is
currently the law of the land these
confirmation hearing is known to anybody
any favors because they actually make
the answers more vague not less vague
and that's the fault of the Democrats
who have politicized assurance to the
point where anybody who disagrees with
them about a case must immediately be
ruled out of line because they actually
want to use the judiciary as a way of
cramming down their own policy
preferences we have to say thank you
right now and like to thank you to our
friends over and my patriot supply right
now if you are concerned North Korea is
making all sorts of noises about violent
things that they want to do they just
released a video yesterday about how
want to blow up a u.s. ship they fired a
missile at Japan it failed thank God but
there are real threats out there and
emergencies happen when you least expect
them if you call eight eight eight eight
oh three 14 13 right now or go to
prepare with Ben calm right now prepare
with Ben calm you can do something that
will make your family significantly more
likely to be safe in an emergency for
just $99 get a four-week emergency food
supply for just 99 bucks earthquake
tornado fire I mean there are plenty of
reasons why terrible things happen in
life natural disasters man-made
disasters and the government can't
always get to you for a little while and
that's why it's important that you have
a four-week emergency food supply on
hand for just $99 the folks in my
parents applied to it better than
anybody right now go to prepare with Ben
compris been calm and order it my team
says that the meals taste really good
prepare with Ben calm 8888 03 14 13 8 8
8 8 03 14 13 again it's basically a
one-time investment in your safety
because these things last forever and
that makes the board at least for dozens
of years i think is the case like 20
years they last up to and so you know
you maybe in 20 years you have to
reinvest for 99 bucks but for the moment
you're pretty well set so go to prepare
with Ben calm make sure that you are
prepared in case of emergency it's the
least thing you can do for your family
okay so course it does a really good job
and and Gorsuch you know does is is very
solid in these hearings he navigates all
the shoals well the Democrats make fools
of themselves they just keep saying
stupid things over and over and over
again just repeatedly and it's a great
moment for Trump right this would be the
best moment for Trump if we weren't all
distracted with Russia stuff and Trump
care stuff and all the other things that
Trump is busy shooting himself in the
foot would so Democrats have been
struggling because they don't actually
know what to do with this so what
they've decided is that they're going to
come up with in an alternative strategy
they can't actually lay a glove on
Gorsuch so what do they do to Brian
Williams the fake news anchor on MSNBC
he says that it is obviously tough to
lay a glove on Gore said she knows what
he's doing stuff to lay a glove on this
guy I didn't see a single glove laid on
him this has been a slam dunk in terms
of his initial cuit choose an eighth
you're going to see some of the more
intensive questioning but they have not
as you put it laid a glove on him and
and you know they're they're upset about
this what do they do Chris map your
state because a month away show and come
out here come back no Karthik why I know
you guys eat ah let's talk about go it's
about starting to fix the system a
president nominates a Supreme Court
justice the Senate deliberates on the
nomination we will not get back to such
respect if we let Trump exploit the
vacancy mitch mcconnell created we
cannot allow these two opportunities to
complete what we call in basketball the
alley you play one guy throws the ball
high up there above the basket and the
guy standing there right underneath jams
it in I don't want to see Donald Trump
stuff his nominee through the hoop why
because it's not his turn it's Marie
Garland's turn and everyone knows it
vote nay on Gor such demand the 60 votes
and don't give them the Trump it's not
this guy's turn it's not his guys turned
and all the charm and dancing a mr. nice
guy it's not going to change it it's not
about gorgeous or even Trump it's about
Mitch McConnell and the brand of
low-level politics he stands for get it
don't let him go let him please don't
let me take a 3-pointer then there's a
rebound that's a free throw line and
Jordan goes up and then the Alianza
Scottie Pippen gems it through you
shouldn't do that with judges because
judges don't fit through hoops that's
the thing then sting lemon praying
explain you right now it's good now
yellow he's sick come as a shoot talk
about basketball well show some Lakers
hot so their new case is basically the
gorse ish is a great nominee but he
can't be put through because the
Republicans refused to vote on Merrick
garland who's president obama's nominee
to fill Scalia slot this isn't going
anywhere let the Democrats blow
themselves up on this one it should be a
great moment for Trump now as we
continue we're going to talk about two
not so great moments for term plus there
is a breaking news story that I have to
tell you about a couple of stories that
are I think going to you know i'll talk
about political fallout from them but
they're pretty incredible stories we'll
talk about them but you're gonna have to
go to daily wire calm and subscribe
right now for that eight dollars a month
got you a subscription to daily wire.com
right now if you become an annual
subscriber you get a free signed copy a
magical signed copy of the most
comprehensive book on democrats ever
sort of written reasons to vote democrat
a comprehensive guide by michael knowles
the Amazon bestseller sold tens of
thousands of copies making a sickening
amount of money off of it but we are
giving it to you for free
and you get to see you get a free signed
copy at daily wired com when you become
an annual subscriber or if you just want
to listen to the rest of the show later
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud make
sure that you leave us a rating we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
United States
[Music]
you